maybe we play a
couple slower ones from this tournament
i'm gonna hop in
still an hour to go maybe we get a few
games in
it has been a very long time since i
played
um
you can see here
my question mark rating for rapid
casa cooley corley's playing
not surprised
he likes his rapid
great time control
now with this lower
time control
you have to watch out for the sneakiness
it's the one thing
you know
like right now
how many uh how many are betting that
this has already been clicked into in my
opponents
maybe
a stream sniping
all right well
i had this earlier right in the blitz
game
d4 does not
have as much support anymore so
let's put that guy right where he
belongs
and see the reaction you go here
it's not that okay so this is
different
how different
well
this is making the most sense to me
c5
with b2 now protected
this is paving the way for many
different moves that are converging on
the dark squares the knight on c5 the
bishop here pinning a knight that'll
defend d4
this check really shouldn't be any
bother
i'm going to sneak in c5 and i think
white should be going with
c3 yeah
so now i think i want to take
yeah
if i develop my knight to c6 this pawn
goes
so i'm gonna go with this and then
develop my knight
you may have been considering bishop
tags if bishop captures was there i was
going to play my knight here and then
next
develop my knight
so i'm going to start with this one
still
still trying to chip away at d4 okay
need to be careful here
move order is important taking like this
i lose
because of queen a4
however if i take with the bishop first
bishop knight and then check
i could fall back with the knight
so what's the short story
i should take with the bishop first if
i'm going to win the pawn
i'm going to try and win that guy
and
i'm not seeing why i shouldn't
chop away
this is a valuable bishop but i am
taking a valuable pawn
same story with the bishop check as a
follow-up
my knight covers that square unleashing
an attack here
all right let's chop
queen a4 doesn't do anything right away
let's do it
okay
well now i'm feeling very comfortable
because my night gets to stay in a
stable square
and
not only am i up a pawn
but i have now because of these double
isolated pawns
a beautiful outpost on e5
which i drew a lot of attention to in an
earlier blitz game
where i was down upon
and have the dark square bishop i don't
have the dark square bishop here
but
still feeling pretty good about my
position
my opponent doesn't have a dark square
bishop that's really the main one that
could potentially take advantage of
these weakened dark squares h6 primarily
offering a knight exchange
i don't think i want to undouble the
knights
i also don't want to allow knight takes
knight to have double def pawns
i think
i'm going to play e6
and be okay with the discovery against
my queen for a move
so
some night move
is there rooks hit my hits my queen but
knight on e5 a queen on e5
i i kind of want to get something like
uh
i i'm open to every every type of
exchange okay so right now i should uh
look forward to improving this guy
i don't want to have my queen there
all day
defending
a knight on f6 this is a half open file
so need to take some
care over any piece that might be on the
f file
e5 is in this night's cross hairs
so
let's do it
maybe i could even
create an inconvenience and i'm not so
sure how much of an inconvenience that
would really be
tell you what let's just go
here
uh
yeah let's let's go here
okay
let's go here
now i want to be a little careful i
don't want to take because maybe they
take with the pawn that that right there
is very helpful
to me because now
i get to
take with this guy which opens up the c
file the c6 square primarily
for this bishop
where it will be very effective
also without the knight on f3
a queen on g5 can be very good
there's not much you could do about that
either queen can get to g5 this is a
nice controlled position
the bishop isn't
bothering me
i remain up upon
and i'm
just steps away from completing my own
development
i guess i could be
looking for some tactics
if my opponent is vulnerable on
protected pieces and such
not seeing any of that
so from here we just make
the the simple moves i'm gonna go with
this guy
because
maybe
now we'll go with this guy
this knight is a very good defender of
f7
i was kind of thinking maybe there's
some something here with the queen
moving okay i should feel feel
comfortable initiating the exchange here
and then getting to the c file
my bishop supports that move
okay
go here
even if this pawn falls
it's still excellent
um
i have to be a little careful of this
move
it's the cleanest way
tell you what i'm going to go here
just watch over this i have to have to
be careful of my time
maybe i'm at this point where i have to
shut up and move
we'll see
between there so this pos this might be
a move
you're hitting this pawn this is a
little sensitive
some tricks here
can be annoying
yeah
i don't like doing this but i'm still
going to do it
babysitting d6
maybe this is a nice improvement pawn on
h4 queen on g3 maybe queen g5 first
i still like keeping this queen around
to watch out for sacrifices on e6
i don't want this position to go out of
control
i want to allow my opponent some trick
on e6
okay
they've released any pressure against e6
uh i like this idea to expand
this is helpful i start to think about
mating nets as soon as there's a pawn on
h4 a knight on g3 pawn on h4 rook on the
back rank that kind of stuff
um
so let's sneak that one in there
still not seeing any accidents happening
with this night
it's crossing my mind after every move
but
just not seeing uh
it's going to be tough because this
night is so good okay so they're trying
to get rid of that guy
totally understandable
um
i think i just want to initiate the
exchange
i'll go ahead and initiate the exchange
and then
replace that knight
with
queen
queen on e5
queen on e5
rook f4
e5 will sting
maybe threatening to flush this queen
away from the defense of e3
she has these two though
still maybe this and then d5
i need to activate my rook
still
staring at my own pawns
or maybe we
we centralize first
off for a queen exchange i'm okay with
doubled pawns
i'm still up upon another thing that
tips in my favor is this pawn
coordinated with my bishop in
bishop specific endings
i'll always have some target a fixed
pawn on a light square
okay and now i could go ahead and win
upon
oh i could take straight away
i'll take straight away
and they could get the pawn back but
then the rook is going to be out of play
rook f4 is what is the way i'm seeing
they win the pawn back
many approaches okay
just gonna
glue my bishop in there and then
activate my rook while the rook is off
sides
might as well exchange
and activate my rook
i'm up two pawns now
and should have the more active rook
control the only open file
and let's not get into some calculation
based position
let's just address my address my
opponent's threats
and slowly improve my king position
these kind of things
the beautiful square for the king
flush their king back
take on poisson
set up a trick if rook takes i could
still go there the follow-up deflection
let's start with that one
plenty of ways to do it from here
i'm not inconvenienced by my rook
having to defend this pawn
it's a
multi-purpose rook
it's only ever a blink away from getting
to the second
and now that there isn't any more
pressure on my apon i'm going to go
hunting for pawns
i'm gonna go for this one
and then save this pawn
and now hunt this guy next
so this construction right here cannot
be disrupted their king is shouldered
off
and
[Music]
i could go for the chop
and next here here we'll win the pawn
i guess they could go here meeting this
with that but still
no issue there
take the pawn the king is
on the edge now
and this is one of the main benefits
whenever you're up some material
almost every little exchange is going to
be benefiting you
because you're winning the king and pawn
ending
and there's plenty of time remaining to
to
push the pawns to victory lane just
watch out for skewers
this one should be in the bag
we're getting there
and we'll make it really simple new and
get the rooks off
in a couple
no stalemates
could have given some checks first if i
wanted that would probably have been
most precise
ponds may be able to do it all on their
own
this stage
mate
a little bit
one
not here that'd be still mate let's give
them one square
then we got mate in the corner
all right they resigned back to
tournament land
you